[Music]
Actually, there are a lot of interesting costumes for this guy. I
just recently got a lamp with a lamp.
Then there is a space to choose from.
Foreign politicians and Japanese politicians.
There are quite a few names for laughing people. I collect and display rare face stones
.
Yeah
[Music]
hebu japan js 2 r Gentil you with me
miter Oh
[Music]
pou dou dou
40 of those collected 4  Starting from
my teens, there was a place where I was a middle-aged horse. At one point, the person's name Sekito changed a little. That's why
I moved to the Honda people's area in the month of doing
it
.  ge
There are so many people gathered, so I'm trying to hear that, right
? There are about 1000 people in all,
nore zu cars tx pending
you can be to do It's
really steady to collect this cow.  If
you walk steadily, you won't be able to do it yourself.
I'm collecting it by publishing it like this little by little.
[Music]
Boo Boo e 4 c
carender tend to do cd the voodoo
People often come to this kind of place, right? I think there are people who are collecting human face stones, but I don't think there are people who are
doing it on a large scale like at home.
I want to take over and spend an hour there for a long time. When I
say
[music]
,